selon vous qui ah oui très intéressant
c'est qui et c'est pas Benoît selon vous
qui a récemment déclaré à regretter
c'est chirurgie esthétique
non non Nabilla ouais c'est la semaine
prochaine
[Rires]
donc effectivement pardon je mets tout
que c'est le talent c'est Nabilla qui a
dû récemment subir une opération de
chirurgie esthétique parce qu'en fait
elle explique que elle dormait toujours
du même côté et du coup elle est ce
qu'on appelle une crevaison de seins
c'est du faux de dormir du même côté il
a percé il s'est réveillé un matin il
avait une crevaison comme une bagnole
ça se change et ben c'est ce qu'elle dit
donc elle dit
petite sur une de mes prothèses
mammaires voilà c'est un peu abîmé je
pense que je dormais toujours du même
côté il y a un 5 et plus plat j'ai un
simple plat t'imagines le matin au petit
déjeuner ton mec qui dit oh tu as
crevé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est plus cher que 4 pneus finalement
tu as deux pneus offerts de pneus
achetés mais tu as raison mais les seins
maintenant souvent il faut déjà les
médecins qui te font souvent le sein ils
se disent vous payez le premier deuxième
étoffert j'allais pas en faire qu'un de
toute façon tu vois mais surtout il dit
qu'elle va profiter de cette opération
pour réduire totalement ses protection
mais qu'elle peut pas attention elle
peut pas les réduire de beaucoup parce
que sinon ça va être moche
un peu toutes les femmes qui sont posées
des prothèses en disant attention elle
avait déjà changé
cette mode de Kim Kardashian il y avait
des culs énormes dessins énormes et
maintenant kim Kardashian à lancer cette
nouvelle mode vous faites toute plate à
la Jane Birkin problème c'est qu'elles
ont toutes des prothèses les tissus donc
les mains sont détendus donc c'est tout
un prêt il faut tout refaire les
coutures et tout
vous voyez les photos prises au Zéniths
vous voyez les vergetures parce que la
peau elle a une résistance mais je gagne
une certaine limite quand même il faut
dire Mathieu c'est quand même important
pour toutes les jeunes femmes ou pas
forcément jeunes qui veulent se faire
refaire les seins la durée de vie d'une
prothèse c'est 10 à 15 ans
ce qui est importante surtout c'est que
je vous répète pas tout ce qu'elle dit
mais elle dit voilà aujourd'hui les
tatouages la chirurgie esthétique si
vous voulez en faire c'est un petit peu
faites pas tout d'un coup et elle dit
moi je regrette ce côté bimbo j'étais
jeune et elle a l'air tout le plus jeune
maintenant tous les influenceurs le font
alors c'est un peu tard mais attention à
la chirurgie ne faites pas trop faites
pas trop de tête de tatouages Matt
Pokora est en train d'enlever les siens
donc pour une fois que Nabilla dit un
truc intelligent les gars on va
également prendre la tête à la vieille
maintenant c'est très très bien et tout
le monde évolue